la question c'est est-ce que tu trouve
toi que le monde des médias est un
milieu de focus que ce compte a tourné
le dos à toi ton nom n'a pas tourné le
dos le monde des médias ça va et
relativement à ces gentils avec moi way
you lie ne pas tourner le dos non mais
la casta castaldi alors moi j'ai projet
c'est pas comme vous mais c'est vrai que
je j'ai envie de dire bel exemple que
c'est un monde de faux cul ce que damas
syrie c'est pour vous parce que cyril et
il ya encore dix ans n'étaient pas les
alliés d'aujourd'hui et à l'époque on
gênait pas pour vous pour vous marchez
dessus 10 ans après les mecs qui vont
marcher dessus sont présentés vous ça
c'est la preuve absolue pour moi que ce
multi est un monde de faux culs en ce
qui me concerne je les avais que
plusieurs fois avec une fois j'avais
rendez vous d'une boîte de production
dont je tairai le nom j'étais au début
de ma carrière je n'étais pas encore
arrivé à haut niveau entre guillemets et
je monte les escaliers et la porte du
producteur était ouverte et j'entends au
téléphone vous manu les castaldi c'est
un vrai connaït les nuls dont je sais
que j'étais à wigan chelsea à l'été sauf
que des as donc ça c'est beau ça va
effectivement aux dites y'a quand même
c'est sympa ça qui m'a dit de venir qui
pourraient former dhabi manu parce
qu'ils trouvent que je suis un humain
qu'on bon j'avais dit que c'est un peu
ce métier mais c'est vrai que c'est dans
les grands moments où j'ai vu la liste
des faux culs challenge et c'est par
exemple et c'est quand j'ai annoncé à m6
que j'allais quitter la chaîne j'étais
en pleine nouvelle star bon c'est vrai
que j'ai fait d'une manière juridique
pour parler comme notre copain avocat et
effectivement ça n'a pas plu à la chaîne
et ils ont décidé avec la production de
l'époque de me sortir de nouvelles stars
donc des gens et qu'ils bossaient depuis
maintenant là sur 6 septembre
dondon des amis quoi il y en aurait un
qui m'aurait dit benji prépare toi parce
que tu vas recevra tu vas tu vas te
pointer son tournage et on espère ne pas
faire l'émission
et quand je me suis posé jeudi on m'a
dit le jour même que je faisais pas
l'émission mais ça c'est très dur
tf1 ça s'est terminé un peu bizarrement
parce qu'effectivement bon j'avais eu
jamais j'ai eu des galères j'ai eu un
échange moto est comme gelée dire sur
sur rtl je pense que j'ai été un peu
inquiété à juste titre d'ailleurs ce que
j'ai personne n'est parfait mais c'est
vrai que quand on m'a dit voilà on va
mettre un terme au contrat parce que tu
vois la sétoise haute autant être libre
c'est quand même mieux voilà bon je
comprends très bien j'avais un gros
contrat et ils l'ont annulé j'étais
parfaitement d'accord sauf que quand
j'ai reçu le courrier du coup on m'a dit
cher monsieur
on vous licencier pour faute grave a dit
line en foot comme non faut pas exagérer
quand même parce que entre autres
séparés en mon père mais dès que j'ai
fait une connerie
un peu c'est vrai donc effectivement il
ya en tout et vous étiez dans
l'approximation perpétuer approximatif
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que les
exemples ne sont ceux qui ont été
détruits
ouais moi je connais je viens sur ce
pour moi c'est un monde de faux cul
parce que pour moi j'aime pas quand tu
te rates à rennes dans un endroit et que
ça rigole trop que cette souris trotter
gentil thébaux j'adore ce que tu fais
rappelle moi enfin le truc tu es tu as
bien aimé sabeg est donc pour moi c'est
des faux cul oui ça te vire du jour au
lendemain un jour devenir et nous virer
tu sais pas pourquoi on joue pas ici
vous saurez pourquoi mais rien n'a rien
vraiment un moment il ya un truc qui te
qui tient c'est le pognon dire que y'a
un moment quand un animateur un peu
reconnus ou un bon chroniqueur rouge tu
fais des audiences et donc jusque là on
tient on tient parce que même si à un
moment on veut dégager
on tient pas ce que tu fais des
résultats puis tout d'un coup tu as 3 4
mais qu'un en coulisses qui te si le
truc et qui te disent ouais mais tu sais
été moins bon quand même là et à des
mecs comme ça en coulisses et tout le
monde lui et c'est ça il faut que nos
patrons puissent tenir le capot et de
tenir le jour où ton patron te sous déjà
plus t'es mort parce que les hyènes
arrivent ils arrivent ils sont vingt
finir c'est vrai que c'est un monde de
faux culs c'est vrai que c'est un monde
d'hypocrites mais en même temps on pour
tous on y va tous nous mêmes ce métier
voilà on aime ce métier parce que c'est
un métier il faut être honnête c'est un
métier qui est bien payé c'est un métier
où tout est content il ya des lumières
il ya du maquillage les gens quand ils
viennent au boulot le matin les maquis
pas on les applaudit passez un bon
métier donc faut prendre l'idée faut
ancrer l'idée en soi de se dire c'est un
monde de focus un mode hypocrite
le jour on va me virer comme benjamin
qu'il le dit marcel de cette chose